what is like your most epic bomb failure
experience well I I open I've opened for
Aries Spears several times I have to
because he only books white opener right
that was a big controversy after our
interview yeah yeah yeah and and he the
first time we worked together there was
a regular show host feature Aries it's
great I loved it
second time I get there it's two-man
show just me and Aries and I'm better at
that now but for a long time
me hitting the stage first is not the
way to go and we need somebody even
someone just to come up and give
announcements but that it is alright
yeah Aries Spears will be here soon
right but the whole weekend was good but
the late show Friday I was on stage and
the audience was just quiet I was just I
did joke after joke and they were just
not into it and then like some some guy
made a weird noise in the audience and I
was like oh someone's dying out there
and he goes no you're dying
like I just ranked down because he was
so right I was like I don't I don't even
know what to say to that how far into
the set was that I think I had about 10
minutes to go so early but I think I
left the stage a bit early I never do
that I always do time but I was like you
know what Aries is gonna do 90 minutes
anyway I'm just gonna get out of here
what was the makeup of the audience uh
well I you know it's hard to say I mean
but you know Aries is not total like an
urban comic you know it but yeah I think
he had a lot of free tickets on that
Late Show and I think free ticket people
just tend to be not invested in the show
yeah they're like we don't care about
this we got free tickets we're paying
$30 for drinks
we don't care yeah yeah I've been there
man I've definitely been there where
you're just it's even like five minutes
in and it's not going well and you're
like I still have 20 more minutes yeah
to figure something out here yeah that's
why if that's happening to me after a
few jokes I like to say I'll go that's a
good joke my I'll go that's a good joke
guys you can laugh at these you know
feel free to get in here last
these jokes let's have a good time yeah
yeah that's where that we're having a
good time I mean me and my wife actually
started saying that to each other you
know we just be like we're having a good
time but I started saying that on stage
for the shows when when it didn't seem
like people were having a good time I
would just go hey we're having a good
time I don't like to ask I like to tell
we're having a good time
do you find that almost coerces them
into oh I guess we are having a good
time yeah I mean my thought is that a
lot of times if you're not doing well
the audience either feels bad for you or
they feel like this is what you do all
the time they're like oh this guy must
bomb all the time so I like to let them
know this is not how my shows normally
go mm-hmm you can laugh at these jokes
get in here and then I feel like that
they see a real side to you they're like
all right this is a real person up here
yeah he's self-aware he notices that
we're not into it and any seems to be
okay with it
[Music]
I breath